[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: The 2021
State of DevOps Report
released last year.
It contained findings
about how teams navigate
key areas of software delivery.
We talked with one of the
researchers, Dustin Smith,
about the report's
section on team culture.
What did this section
of the report focus on?
DUSTIN SMITH: We look at
how team culture impacts
a team's ability to perform.
We've done that
for several years.
And, as I had mentioned, we
look at a lot of factors,
and team culture
tends to be one that's
really important because
it has a direct connection
to performance both for a team's
ability to deliver software
quickly and reliably and meet
their profitability goals,
their organizational goals.
SPEAKER 1: What separates
elite teams from the rest?
DUSTIN SMITH: Yeah, when we
look at good team culture,
we use Ron Westrum's model of
organizational culture, which
has essentially a
taxonomy that runs
the gamut from a pathological
team that blames people
for making errors, all
the way to bureaucratic,
that has a little more
red tape set up within it,
to a generative team culture,
which is performance-oriented,
it's highly cooperative, and
a culture of no blame, right?
And so what does a culture
of no blame look like?
Well, you have to be willing
to give your teams some room
to make mistakes.
And they have to feel like
if they make a mistake
they're not going to
be punished for that.
And this creates a culture where
you're more reflective, where
you know that if you take a
chance, if you take a risk,
even if you fail, you're still
going to learn from that,
and you'll be better
the next time you
try something like that.
And this creates
a group of people
that then want to innovate
more and they're not
afraid of doing so.
They don't need to just
stay within the rails of how
the team was originally
designed to operate.
And we find that teams
that are like that
are higher performing.
SPEAKER 1: What is a
generative team culture?
DUSTIN SMITH:
Generative team culture
comes from Ron Westrum's model
of organizational culture,
which runs from all the way to
a pathological team culture,
which is--
punishes kind of people
for making mistakes,
to a bureaucratic team
culture, all the way
to a generative
team culture, which
focuses not on the mistakes
but how you can improve
from the mistakes, and
how best to work together
to improve over time.
They're performance-oriented
they want--
they see opportunities to
get better and capitalize
on those things.
SPEAKER 1: What is the
makeup of generative teams?
DUSTIN SMITH: What
we find is that when
teams are made up of a group
of people that are diverse
and come from
different backgrounds,
and they feel like when
they bring up something
from their expertise, when they
have an opinion or an idea,
that their team will
be accepting of that.
Maybe not everyone will agree on
it but their opinion is valued
and there can be value
taken from their point.
When teams feel like
they can do this,
they feel comfortable
sharing ideas
and that they'll be supported
by the people around them,
they feel a part of that group,
they're higher performing
but they're also less likely to
experience burnout as a result.
SPEAKER 1: How does team
culture relate to burnout?
DUSTIN SMITH: So we used
Christine Maslach's definition
of burnout for this report.
And we looked at
things like, do you
feel exhausted when
you're doing your work?
Are you bringing those
negative feelings home,
and is that affecting your
home life outside of work?
Are you able to actually
separate yourself
from your work?
Are you starting to
feel cynical about that?
And we put all of that
together and we look at which
teams are experiencing that.
And we find that teams
with a good team culture.
So are they generative?
People feel like they belong,
do they feel included,
are half as likely to
experience burnout.
And why that's so
important is that we're
going through a pandemic
right now and a lot of people
are experiencing burnout.
SPEAKER 1: So
what's the core idea
of this section of the report?
DUSTIN SMITH: I think
trying to motivate people
to focus not just on what are
the technical practices that
need to be implemented
on a team in order
to be successful but
also look at your people
over those things,
and focus on, how
can we make our people
feel more supported?
How can they take small risks?
How can they feel like
they can innovate?
Focusing on those things
are a win for employers,
for businesses because it,
like I mentioned earlier,
reduces burnout, reduces
attrition, all while increasing
productivity and
organizational goals.
SPEAKER 1: Where can
users go to learn more?
DUSTIN SMITH: That's
a great question,
for everything DevOps
at Google you can go
to cloud.google.com/DevOps.
There, you can find the
State of DevOps 2021 Report.
Like I mentioned,
it's completely free.
You just need to sign up and
you can download the report.
But there are also
other assets there.
If you want to read about any
of these individual capabilities
that we mention here, for
example, team culture, burnout,
we have specific articles
written about those topics
and how you could
apply those practices.
And finally, we have
the DevOps Quick Check,
which also allows you to measure
your own performance, a really
five-question survey, and
get a rough idea of how
are you performing
relative to the industry.